Evet
evet sizi
1920'ler Efor fabrikalarına götüreceğim
tek bir ürün hayal edin çok sayıda
üretilecek çok ucuza üretilecek amaç
ortasını FIAT sırtından alıp arabaya
bindirmek yani halkın arabasını üretmek
ve bu
1920'li yıllardan beri tutulan kayıtlara
göre halen üretilmiş ve Satılmış tüm
araçlar içerisinde 8'inci sıraya sahip
olan model t yi konuşuyoruz yani
kitlesel üretimi üretim devrimini
konuşuyoruz üretim maliyetleri düşürmek
üretim süresini azaltmak için her şeyi
düşünüyorlardı herfort siyah olduğu
sürece istediğiniz renk araca sahip
olabilirsiniz ama siyah olduğu sürece
sloganıyla yola çıkmıştı Aslında bu
görüşünün arkasında temel bir ekonomik
gerekçe vardı boyahanede ki süreyi
azaltmanın yolu en çabuk kuruyan renk
olan siyah seçmekte v1910 4.25 yılları
arasında üretilmiş tüm model T
araçlarının rengi siyahtı Ford şirketine
bu bu büyük başarıyı herif orda
o insanlara Ne istediklerini
sorsaydım daha hızlı giden at üretirdim
diyebilecek özgüveni veren şeyi üretim
planlama ve
örgütlenmede yapılmış olan yenilikler di
Ve zamanın efsane markası ve Bir Efsane
bir marka ve üretim kültürü oluştu Şimdi
geriye dönüp baktığımızda o en iyi
mühendislerinin çalıştığı
endüstriyel Devriminin gerçekleştiği o
Ford fabrikalarında bir gün bir makine
bozulur
bu ve üretim tamamen durur
Fiat Ford mühendisleri arızayı
gidemeyince iş Diamond S4 döner Şahin
Max General elektrikte efsaneleşmiş bir
bilim insanı bir matematik dâhisi ve bir
elektrik sihirbazı dır
çözecekse bu problemi şu taymez
çözecektir bu mühendisleri Style meksi
kapıda karşılarlar gıda içeri girerken
başlar Ama tuhaflıklar Şahin Max
mühendislere dönüp bana bir kağıt Bir
Kalem Bir de tebeşir getirirler bozuk
makinenin yanına gider bütün gün
makineyi dinler defterinde hesaplar
yapar notalar geceyi de fabrikada
geçirir ikinci gün makineyi dinlemeye
not almaya devam eder artık
mühendisleri Style metre şüpheli
gözlerle bakmaya başlamıştır ki Tam da o
sırada şu Diamond bana merdiveni
getirirler merdivenin Üzerine çiğ bu
generatörün üzerine tebeşirle işaret
koyar ve işareti koyduğum yerdeki
parçayı değiştirin çalışacaktır
gerçekten dediği gibi olur üretim
yeniden başlar herkes mutludur ama herif
Ordu Mutluluğu sadece iki gün sürer
çünkü Ford fabrikalarına tarihin en
ilginç
faturalarından biri gelmiştir
danışmanlık faturası Şahin Mehmet
danışmanlık faturasının açıklama
bölümüne verdiği hizmet yerine kendi
ismini koymuş Time et diye ve fatura
tutarı 10.000 dolar o dönem için oldukça
yüksek bir tutar Ford küplere biner
geldi Yattı kalktı tebeşirle işaret
koydu neyin 10 bin doları söyleyin
ostime etse faturayı detaylandır sındır
tyt faturayı detaylandır
Ama bu sefer fatura iki kalemden
oluşmaktadır 1. kalem ve mi işareti
koymak bir dolar ikinci kalem işareti
nereye koyacağını bilmek
9999 dolar İşte bu tarihin en anlamlı
faturası olarak kayda geçti
bu işareti nereye koyacağını bilmek
tarihin ilk okuryazar toplumunun
yaşadığı coğrafyamızda iş zekası
yüksektir İki kere iki kaç eder diye
sorulduğunda
alırken 3 satarken 5 eder diyen akıl
Aslında başarının iki önemli bacakta
yani satın alma ve satışta olduğuna
vurgu yapar buna rağmen dünyanın en
değerli 500 markası içerisinde hiçbir
Türk şirketini sokamıyorum düz buna
rağmen
şirketlerimiz 2 üçüncü ve dördüncü
kuşaklara emanet edebilecek kadar yaş
atamıyoruz buna rağmen
en yeni ekonomi ile uyumlu yunikornlar
Yani tekboynuzlar üretemiyoruz birinci
değişim dalgası tarım Devri miydi tarım
Devriminin üretim aracı toprakta ikinci
değişim dalgası sanayi üretim devriydi
Sanayi Devrimi'nin üretim aracı sermaye
7 ve bugün yaşadığımız 3. büyük devrimin
yani dijital devrimin
bu üretim aracı bilgi değil bilgelik
şirketlerimizin tüm süreçlerini
dijitalleşti rerack verir üretmesi
gerekiyor Bu üretilen verileri işleyip
bilgiye bilgiyi analiz edip bilgeliğe ve
3 görüştür 3 göre dönüştürmemiz
gerekiyor Çünkü artık her bir işletme
veri İşletmesi haline gelmek zorunda
Çünkü artık veri bir Kalkınma meselesi
ve yarışta kimin önde kalacağını
belirleyecek olan şey veriyi nasıl
kullandığımız olacak yol 2006 netflex
21. yüzyılın petrolün Veli olduğunu
çoktan keşfetmiş katma değeri artırmanın
yolunun tavsiye sistemini iyileştirmek
ten geçtiğini çoktan öngörmüş ve Bugün
onu etmelik müşterilerinin de kaçırırım
dizinin ilk bölümünü bitirdiğini
bitirenlerin 2. bölüme ne kadar süre
sonra geçtiğini nerede ileri sardığını
nerede geri sardığını hangi ses tonunu
beğendiğini hangi cihazla bağlandığını
neyi merak ettiğini ve düşüncelerini
biliyor Buna büyük veri mühendisliği
ediyoruz buna müşteri bilmek diyoruz ve
o netflix müşterisinin bir sonraki
davranışını öngörebilmek için bir
sonraki karar anı tahmin edebilmek için
daha da önemlisi
herkese yönelik genele yönelik pazarlama
yerine kişiye özel tasarlanmış pazarlama
geliştirebilmek için her yıl Milyonlarca
dolar biri mühendisliğine yatırıyor ne
için bu daha iyi müşteri istihbaratı
için ne için tekrarlanan satışlar
yapabilmek için
de brüt karlılığın artırabilmek için ama
Daha önemlisi
bu seyreden in seyretmeye de önerdiği
müşteri tabanı oluşturarak kendisine
bordrosu satış temsilcileri oluşturmak
için ve daha da önemlisi
pazarlama 40 için yani satışın ötesine
geçip müşteri sadakatini en üst düzeye
çıkarabilmek için Unutmayalım ki yeni
müşteri kazanmanın maliyeti mevcut
müşteriyi korumanın maliyetinin En az 10
katı bolmart müşterisinin satın alma
kararlarının önündeki tüm engelleri
biliyor çok soğuk Deponun önüne ütü
soğuk alanın önüne gelmiş olan yoğurt
almaya gelmiş olan müşterisinin düşük
fiyat ve temiz hizmet beklentisini zaten
çözmüş O kasları da zaten başarıyı
getirmiş ama şimdi müşterinin zihninde
bir engel daha var gıda güvenliği
İyi o zaman bol Martın burada çözmesi
gerekiyor o yoğurda o yoğurdu taşıyana o
yoğurdu saklayana dağıtana
suçsuz olduğunu ispatlama şansı vermesi
gerekiyor ve yoğurtlu o kadar çok süreç
var ki sürekli inekle başlıyor ineğin
nasıl beslendiği memesinde iltihap olup
olmadığı Yoğurdun hangi süreçlerden
geçtiğini sütün hangi sıcaklıkta taşındı
tır'daki koşullar hepsi önemli
bolmart bu verileri blok zincir üzerine
taşımadan önce
22 günde ulaşabiliyor du ancak
yirmiikigün
Evet şimdi
bütün tedarikçiler bütün paydaşlar Veli
nerede tuttuk larından bağımsız Excel'de
tutabilir Kağıt ortamında tutabilir ama
yapmak zorunda oldukları bir şey var
geçmişin mü değiştirilmesinin mümkün
olmadığı blok Zincire bu verileri
taşımak zorunda da ki müşteri Yoğurdun
tüm geçmişini görebilsin Tüm geçmiş en
yüksek şeffaflıkla izle Ne Bilsin ne
için 22 koca günü iki saniye
düşürebilmek için ne için müşteri
memnuniyetini en üst düzeye çıkarabilmek
maliyetlerini düşürebilmek için ve
unutmayalım
bu en önemli veri kaynağımız Biz en
mutsuz mutsuz mutsuz müşterilerimiz dir
bir Peki bizim firmalarımız da durum ne
bu şirketlerimiz de
bilanço ve Finansal tabloları
istediğimde bana hocam hangisini
getirelim diyor ya Bilensoy istedik
hangisini getirelim diyor çünkü ben
rekat T3 bilanço var Vergi Usulüne göre
ayrı uluslararası finansal raporlama
standartlarına göre ayrı ve üzerinden
gece kamyon geçmiş gerçek bir eğlence
ayrı gerçeğini getirin varlığını kabul
etmediğimiz bir sorunu çözeriz diyoruz
bilanço geliyor Bu sefer de dönüyoruz
Bu bir bakıyoruz ki iki ay öncesinin
bilançosu iki ay önceki performansa
bakarak bu şirketin geleceğini dair
edeceğiz
doktora giderken geçen yılın kan
testiyle mi gidiyorsunuz
bu velev ki bütün süreçler bitti veriler
geldi mi üstüne Team bilançoyu
okuyamıyor analiz edemiyor yorumla
yemiyor ve Halbuki üst yönetimde insan
kaynakları satış pazarlama dahil
hepimizin hakim olması gerekiyor benim
işim değil deme lüksümüz yok artık şu
Çünkü o bilen Şuradaki ticari alacak
şirketin pazarlama zekâsının oradaki
duran varlıklar şirketin yönetim
zekâsının
sol taraftaki stoklar şirketin üretim
ürün yönetimi satınalma Yalın üretim
zekâsının Kısa vadeli borç uzun vadeli
borç kompozisyonu şirketin finansal
yönetim zekâsının gelir tablosu şirketin
kul kablosundaki kur farkı zararı
şirketin risk yönetimi zekasının bir
sonucu
bu ve şirketin bütün hiç zekasını
yansımış olduğu veriyi eksik
oluşturuyoruz gecikmeli hazırlıyoruz ve
okuyamıyoruz
o
firmalarımız ürettiği ekmeği
o fırınımız
lastik jimmy's ürettiği lastiğin berber
imiz kırkbeş dakikalık vermiş olduğu
hizmetin gerçek maliyetini bilmiyor
A bu çok önemli sorun çünkü
Fiat Fiat damada Stratejik yönetimde
satınalmada pazarlamada şirketin
kaderini belirleyecek en önemli şey en
temel şey maliyet muhasebesi
ki bilanço Biz şirketlerimiz için gelir
tablosunu ki şirketin bütün için
hazırlıyoruz Halbuki her bir ürün her
bir müşteri her sürü sattığımız şehir
her ihracat yaptığımız ülke için gelir
tablosu hazırlamalıyız hazırlamalıyız
vede her bir ürün için şirket için şehir
için ve ülke için
maliyetler düştükten sonra ne kaldı brüt
kârlılık Bali yetler ve dağıtılmış
faaliyet giderleri düştükten sonra ne
kaldı yani faaliyet karlılığı bunları
hesaplayabilir mememiz gerekiyor ki
şimdi bana soruyorlar ne yapacağız Hocam
bunu hesaplayınca bunu hesapladığımız da
kârda olduğumuzu sandığımız
ürünlerimizde gerçekten zarar ettiğinizi
Dolayısıyla ürün gamımız dan çıkarmamız
gerektiğini göreceğiz bunu
hesapladığımız da kârlılık kaygısıyla
fiyatını indiremeyeceğin izi sana o
günlerde fiyatı indirip pazarı yerle
Yeksan edebileceğiz verev ki her şey bir
kenara Bu detayda ürün bazında gelir
tablosu bilen şu hazırlayabilen
şirketler bunu yapabilmiş olmak zaten
Stratejik yönetimde dijitalleşmede
dibine vurmuş vurmuş olmak demektir
Dolayısıyla veri toplamanın Tabii ki
ciddi bir maliyeti var burada her zaman
şu ülkeye sadık kalmak lazım Ne gerekti
Ne kadar gerekli ne zaman gerekli
şirketlerimizin süreçlerini
incelediğimizde her yerde israf var
heryerde aşırı üretim aşırı stok
gereksiz bekleme gereksiz taşıma
gereksiz sok
bu şap onlara bakıyorsun 1940 yılında
yalan üretimi kurarken
09060 israfla yola çıktılar ve
bu Tai Chi oh no o efsane sözünü O zaman
kullanmıştı insanlar işyerlerine
çalışmaya değil düşünmeye giderler
bu Starbucks'ı düşünün 40 metrekare 40
metrekarede tahsilat Finans satış
pazarlama her şey tüp metrekare
bu yap onlar ne diyor bugün Yalın üretim
teknikleri en iyi uygulayan sektörlerden
bir hizmet sektörü toka yok et Oka yok
et
o toka hata yok engelli hatayı engelle
ama hatayı olmadan engelle sipariş
vermek için geliyorsunuz hepiniz
starbucks'a Ne diyorsunuz venti büyük
bardak Misto sütü bol olsun ekstra sıcak
olsun ahududu şuruplu Olsun olsun bu
olsun Hepsini yazıyor bardağı üzerine en
sonda ismini yazıyor Ne için o bardak
bir bardak değil o bardak bir iş Emir
kartı yan taraftaki üretim hatasız olsun
yan tarafta doğru ürün doğru müşteriye
doğru şekilde teslim edildi edebilir
edilebilsin diye Bugün biz kendi
şirketlerimiz de dönüp baktığımızda
Yalın yönetim ilkelerinin maalesef çok
az bir kısmının çoğunlukla da
hiçbirinin uygulanmadığını gözlemliyoruz
bu
bu şirketlerimiz
ve
kurumsallaşmış olanlar en büyükleri de
dahil olmak üzere şok ciddi yönetsel
sorunlarla karşı karşıya bu şirketi Ben
kurdum diyen kurucu
bu orta filan verebilecek kurucu patronu
falan diyebilecek kuvvetler ayrılığı
mekanizmaları yok
şirketlerimiz de bizden insanlar var
bilen insanlar yok
bu nepotizm yani kardeş eş-dost
kayırmacılığı her yerde icraat ve
yönetim şapkaları birbirine karışmış
vaziyette ve daha da önemlisi
şirketin yönetim kılavuzu olarak kabul
ettiğiniz anayasa yok olanlarda da
anayasayı takan yok İnsan Kaynakları
ayrı bir Krallık satın alma aynı bir
Krallık birbiriyle konuşamayan
onlarca veri silosu
onlarca yönetici var nesiller arası
geçiş problemleri çözülememiş ve şirket
bu
beynit şirketin bedeni kadar büyüyemiyor
O neden ya üst yönetimden en alt
kademeye kadar her yerde tek ses ve tek
akıllı var şimdi bitirmeden önce sizi
altı Ağustos
1945'te götüreceğim altı Ağustos
1945'te sabah saat sekiz rapone
kıyılarına bir bombardıman uçağı
yaklaşıyor Japon radar sistemi bu
bombardıman uçağını farkediyor alarmı
veriliyor ama bir süre sonra
ve baskın uyarısı geri çekiliyor
bu ve karar Merkezi Şu diğer ekle baskın
uyarısını geri çekiyor Diyor ki karar
Merkezi bir ağustos sabah
Güneştepe'de hava pırıl pırıl bu şapon
kıyılarına bu kadar alçaktan bu kadar
yavaş tek bir bombardıman uçağı nasıl
gelebilir olsa olsa keşif uçağıdır
diyerek baskın rüyasını geri çekiyorlar
bu ve o uçak beş dakika sonra hiroşimayı
yerli efsanedir bu şap Onlar bu olaydan
iki önemli ders çıkarıyor birincisi
Samuray dönemi bitmiştir diyorlar bundan
sonra topla kılıçla tüfekle değil
bir insanla yüzer fabrikalarla üretimle
savaşacağız
ama daha da önemlisi ikincisi bundan
sonra tek bir kişinin tek bir sistemin
aklıyla hareket etmeyeceğiz Tek akıllı
yönetilen şirketlerin tek akılla
yönetilen ekonomilerin tek akılla
yönetilen ülkelerin sonunun Hiroşima
olduğunu görüyorlar
bu ve her yere denetim mekanizması
yerleştiriyorlar her yere tek akıldan
ortak akla geçiş bireysel zekâdan
Kolektif zekaya sıçramıştır tarih
değişmeyen olanları değil ona kafa tutan
ları yazar tarih gerçekten isteğini inat
edeni
imkansızı dene yeni ve vazgeçmeli yazar
teşekkür ederim abone ol